[Musique]
llorente est une force de la nature
énergique solide lucide elle aura
bientôt 103 ans je n'ai phase 2 de vivre
le mieux possible de prôner une page aux
auto chargeuse parce que d'hommes
elle habite aujourd'hui en résidence
mais a eu sa maison jusqu'à 96 ans et sa
voiture jusqu'à 98 temps
pour pouvoir continuer à marcher elle
s'est fait remplacer une hanche à l'âge
de 100 ans josserand premier sur l'a10
notre dame à pharmacie à la banque à
bibliothèque on les écoute parler du
dernier siècle et on ne s'ennuie pas
j'ai commencé à enseigner
1,36 à sa saga pièces par année
ce comics et c'était du pays qui était
premier ministre on vous gâte les truies
gp féministe dlt jamais fait dire le
nombre de centenaires comme elle a
augmenté de 16 % en cinq ans au pays
selon le dernier recensement en 2021 il
y avait
1975 centenaire au québec et
9535 au canada
joyeuse
nivelles c'est le 6 mai hélène girard
fêtait elle ses 98 ans en compagnie de
ses filles sa génération les 94 ans et
plus augmentent aussi en flèche 19% de
plus en cinq ans en 2021 ils étaient 25
1615 au québec et 110 1705 au canada
celle que vois pas à quoi je pensais
jamais de me rendre là jamais le secret
c'est de jeu c'est pas bien se nourrit
bien faire attention à nous autres les
gens qui vivent plus vieux ils sont
souvent particulier par rapport aux
autres souvent ils ont eu des meilleures
habitudes devises ont été plus actifs
physiquement mais les grosses
différences idents dans la santé
psychologique sont des gens qui sont
plus résilient c'est des gens aussi qui
sont plus déterminés david lussier
dirige une clinique de la douleur et il
est de plus en plus de patients très
âgés ont été très bons pour traiter le
cancer pour traiter les maladies
cardiaques pour traiter les maladies
cérébrovasculaires donc les gens meurent
moins vite mais on n'a pas réussi encore
à bien traiter que c'est ce que je fais
là habillé traiter l'arthrose la retrait
est aussi arrivé là qu'ovide des
milliers d'années en sont mortes des
milliers d'autres ont souffert des
contraintes sanitaires lorette prince a
dû traverser cinq périodes de
confinement dans son petit logement je
le pose la question mais comment ça se
fait que au québec à victoriaville
fauville c'est comme ça
j'avais mots d'amour y pouvait faire du
conditionnement physique à mersch jeu
s'adapte à tous les jours mais
grâce à la au kobus on est obligé on y
adhère savez c'est assez triste et
désolant à voir à quel point ils se sont
d'intérieur et oublieux large mais il ya
aussi ça a été amplifiée par par l'
isolement et par le manque de
stimulation et d'activité physique
isolement a aussi amplifié leur solitude
quand on a 100 ans les deuils
s'accumulent or nos trois personnes de
notre ami sont décédées en deux mois et
plus j'aime témoins à l'heure de
jeu les vous à partir si ses vielles
derrière deux doigts c'était bien qu'un
que je suis seul j'ai vécu saint quentin
avec mon mari mais je m'encourage tout
le temps j'ai toujours à autre que ça ya
de mieux
tout le temps je me bats tout le temps
je sais que nos personnes aînées on les
met souvent côté était alors on bâtit
descente et puis souvent on les oublie
quand je la vois vieillir je réalise que
un simple téléphone un bon jour une
visite ça fait sa journée ça lui donne
de l'énergie
hélène girard et leurs états ont la
chance d'avoir trois générations de
descendants qui leur donne des nouvelles
et qui les aident à cheminer dans le
québec d'aujourd'hui
les aînés sont au mieux mais même à son
temps être servis dans le réseau de la
santé n'est pas toujours facile si j'ai
besoin de téléphoner et d'acteurs et
c'est un robot qui nous répond le body
toujours je n'ai pas compris maintenant
show ne le maudis c'est un
sinois
sepa et services pour les aînés ce fut
une très bonne décision monsieur
président parce que ex ministre de la
santé du québec réjean hébert fait
aujourd'hui partie du conseil national
des aînés un organisme fédéral dont la
mission est de proposer des idées pour
améliorer leur quotidien tous ne
vieillissent pas aussi bien que laurette
et hélène en deviendra noda à peine dix
ans l'une des nations les plus vieilles
au monde le problème actuellement c'est
qu'au québec et au canada les soins à
domicile sont anémiques il y en a
pratiquement pas lorsqu on se compare
avec les pays européens et les pays
asiatiques des soins à domicile sont
sous développés on s'aperçoit qu'on
prochain dans la difficulté les
restrictions des soins à domicile et si
on améliore la première ligne ok dans
les dix prochains essais nous les
suivent alors c'est ce qu'il faut qu'on
améliore au québec pour pau nous
échapper également c'est même ma
compagne
contente d'avoir discuté de sa vie
hélène nous a même fait une petite danse
avant de partir
ce matin ça va être pire
oui très bien lorette elle nous a confié
son secret pour être encore heureuse à
102 ans de se trouver des choses qui
nous fait brésil
[Musique]
tu peux attendre
ici jean-sébastien cloutier radio-canada
victoriaville